oh no we could have to frame
[Music]
No Mr Bond I will save our project right
away in my a million subscribers I'm
part of the club now loud sigh geez the
club you'll have blown me out the
[__] Club
I'm literally chasing you down easy what
do you wanna know one 450
he's on one 200 in a week you're
literally one Loganville title yeah log
employee to me yes that's true though so
I can I'm not joking when I say can we
please make that Brian's first piece of
merch to be fair I think my cameraman
had mojo before me him came round and
wheezy much the other day no but he also
has this thing of just taking my clothes
without asking me and then turning up to
my house to clean the house wearing my
own [__] yeah my supreme jumper once
actually little boy had to I'm gonna
take that off I should give that one
back you know brand deals have been
[Laughter]
selling that uh name is gonna say yeah
so can I just quickly shout out loud
Brookes for the new sponsorship deal
lots of loudest
do all this this weekend the kickoffs
back it's gonna be Arsenal vs months at
the good game gonna be watching that
it's a bit mad how most people just get
like you know their fee and have to wait
60 days for and you've they've literally
given you a house I'll be absolutely
clear this house is we pick this house
they don't just go we've got a house
ready no not this house yeah I selected
okay we'll give you a house of your
choice most people be happy to find out
the big the big question though does
start Monday of return for season two it
does be the greater friend we have a
greater food we managed to get someone
so I'm grateful for all you're supposed
to put a half chalk in their Lords at
this point is just going straight in on
anyone my other question is how come it
hasn't been or if you know by the time
this goes out you actually definitely
get a picture of him sitting down
signing some form of contract that is an
that was gonna be an easy launch to yet
saw going out there Dave sitting in the
office and Brian man yeah stop yeah stay
back there have been maybe five messages
within there where kids are gone I
appreciate you though as well what you
do for the channel cuz you know you've
got a lot of people who who say you know
need to say I need to thank everyone and
then they didn't mention whose name I'm
just sitting there watching the video
going
[Laughter]
YouTube's any dropout that was amazing
I always knew I was it was going on
largest put one company i've gotta
commentate on me on there was there was
different responses that some of them
went this is the worst day of my life
other people went can you do it with
Stephen Stephen Stephen would be awful
what he can take anything serious like
after all the comedy fights of God no no
no but could you imagine all the us
viewers watching Steve that is going
straight over their head becomes you
choose most hated overnight yeah just be
a commentary of just constant pedo jokes
and my pissed and YouTube just trying to
figure out how to take down this we just
muted and just have the roar of the
crowd home we get in the camera this
time we ended up with you to Shannon
Briggs Johnnie Nelson are going to be
giving us the boxing and I was just in
between fights
I can't wait table you have IM i because
i feel like jonny Nelson's like the more
sensible like technical boxing brain
whereas I think Shannon obviously you
know was boxer but he's crazy real I'm
glad that we've got Joker's all of our
podcasts are job being a good laugh and
jaws yeah the only other person who's
done it like wiggling to actually get
what they're going through as they walk
into the ring and all that him
cuz it's different obviously if we've
got a proper boxer his experience of it
wouldn't be anything like what Joel was
talking about jaws gonna in order filled
so what's Logan feeling right now well
if it's anything he'll feel an extreme
pain in his right knee it's gonna be
terrible for anything and he's gonna be
thinking how JJ's gonna make you know
what well I'll keep walking back that
was how all of this started between God
commentate normally shy Emma but I want
to do it because
in between as well destroyer
sorry Punk you literally put a face time
with Logan Pole in your thumb I actually
don't you can't try to me watching
someone until there's a spider on my
shoulder video streaming that honestly
had me a bit such I because I saw you
tweeted out but couldn't be Arden to
help you out so I'll just I'll just see
the final one you know and it will add
you'd lived up to see we did alright i I
don't I don't think Simon took to it to
others just being like you've got to
stop with this non-stop us it's not it's
just like I would crack really in it but
then yeah because he's like it's the
hardest one of the lot what in so easy
target well no because what point is
that easy then what point is the nicest
like even JJ is a different ball game
the pickin
miniman doesn't it I wouldn't say you
know when you want to hit 2 million in
turn you turn turn under you just turn
on him just quickly go he'll turn on him
but I did anyway
is there anybody sorry wait there
there's someone our ever wonder if Theo
Baker has a like a video stalked away
where it's just a camera on him and he
goes suppose you're wondering how I got
here yeah it's got Elliot Crawford like
tied up in the background of the choice
yeah he looks like a guy who rose to
should fight that would have been a good
place those two electron for Theo Baker
yeah his girlfriend had been obviously
saying some things about me in a video
or something they mean youtuber
girlfriends and can we just keep this
podcast away from YouTube sorry for a
minute
cuz I didn't want to come out and be
like [__] your girl from being saying
about this gentleman cuz I probably saw
she was on e looking after him and she
said I think she just slide those off
because I said basically I took George
sight right in the right a new thing
which I its Elliott said to me it's not
how you think it was and I just thought
lived it I was like fine like why baby
but I after everything George did
finally I would always need your side
and that in that specifically in that
argument I always feel like it's so hard
being a like so many youtubers get so
much heat from each other and I know
they build off it but sometimes it's
just absolutely
destroy someone 900 I don't like the one
thing I remember thinking after I did
that login videos like got a copy also
do many more it just makes you look like
an Aussie if you're in action I remember
with Jack so me and Jack are best pals
no I remember watching bye XO podcasts
when like I actively thought I didn't
like him I'm like you see yourself
making snarky content like it's just a
[__] YouTube video it's not that deep
you know I like it just makes you look
those comments yeah yeah I guess you
have moved in so obviously off the table
everyone yeah yeah yeah yeah wait why is
the gold girl poor an unsuspecting how
badly she's having to clean the whole
place hmm
what is that fantasy or no no it's just
she might have been doing that
how's things number you loves anyway
alright I moved into my god like why did
you live in that place yeah yes yeah
it's really nice my story's over five on
over four stories to satisfy Wow
so I'm gonna hop on someone else after
yeah two for the manager at one mill
head up the roads anyway so what why do
you please new plate and why did we pick
it well or why we moved out was I just
lived in that place for like what 40 or
four years and like naturally I moved
around my whole life so I needed
something new I'm not one of those
people don't like so stay somewhere for
too long I get bored I get comfy last
time I don't podcast that you were
saying to me
weird-looking pruney yes right now we
found that it's still the same lads of
me Kalin Harry and yeah it's just it's
so much nice as well as I was so glad to
go out that places about the tattoo made
me crease he's actually gonna do it he's
actually no no he's actually no yeah I
mean he might not do it though I think
he wants I think he wants to do he wants
to get a tattoo he just has no idea what
but I'm just surprised he decided to go
for a maverick won't be the first one if
he didn't he was like don't make me
throw it on purpose or something
it's a comfy 10 mil views for him yeah
yeah I mean make it do anything I get a
tattoo of him hitting his mum in the
head with the football that was I know
you're all good you get a picture
there's a gaming chair what's that oh my
god
I could do with the game and chair for
downstairs of this mmm OTA across this
void someone's already given you a game
you chide you not know about that
alright okay Alex this is the million
treatment this is that oh I've got just
look at our surroundings before you
tried to salt light you live in a
[__] either way it's not quite it
hasn't been set up who's messy are you
oh gee I'd say seem level you still
mister how was she snaps first she's
like I can't handle this first then she
cleans it it's funny you say that
because since the last podcast it's
actually their one-year anniversary
today he didn't come along because he's
too busy sucking the farts out I'm not
even joking whenever cup raises made the
girl he actively tries to sabotage your
forth and multiply
yeah and I hope many many more years to
come many little bird chips so see it's
summer in the city I don't I don't like
summer in the sea I traveling it's a
pretty [__] event okay well we're gonna
be doing a panel at 5:00 p.m. on
Saturday first that's why we're
no Harry's got jet skis out there so we
all fans out there I'm going out there
we've got I've got a text be like we'll
do a bar crawl and just do jet skis
between islands ours I've got a phat
panel at 5 p.m.
I feel in Turkey 2005 I'm trying to see
some more dolphins I've never been on it
so why do we not get invited to these
it's not I thought when the million came
I'd get I get trapped better but it's
it's not coming yet I thought I'd get
some of the afterglow but so far all
I've seen is you getting treated better
and everyone going by the way it's good
to have you here you Bertie I'm 23 I
think you just about to hit it I've seen
that yeah maybe that's why this has come
through if any I don't know why wheels
got sunglasses on he's got pings so I
got an eye infection so I know a bit I
woke up the other day and I think I was
sore as [__] and I text my ass about it
and then like what you giving me no no I
went back to sleep right and I woke up
and she full-on like thought I had
chlamydia or whatever turns out I just
don't know how to spell sty yeah I just
you know you're like dozy as [__] I was
like I've got a Stein lychees st I wrote
it went back to sleep and she was like
[__] like two hours later I hear so many
stories of people like you put their
girlfriends through absolute [__] and I
just think how you still with such a
lovely girl what what are you expecting
her to break up with the Monroes I
thought I would well then unbelievable
[Music]
we've already been Logan Paul hits help
helps mates maybe maybe we could do that
and then I can link off of this video
makes to you actually weirdly you what
you were there when JJ Logan met for the
first time you actually with that video
so this again so you with fo when the
first time at Logan JJ met but I think
you guys are thinking of a different
time or it was one of the first time
when we're in the Mayweather Jeff yeah
no no I'm talking about right so that
was the very first time and they were
foolin with Super Ball what like two
years ago outside it was with rice gum
as well so ya know he was caught he was
this was just before he was like blown
up he was in the process of blowing up
yeah we met him that was cool when I've
seen that footage but I remember I was
like they had no idea how badly they pop
us were about a cross and like like you
just never know who could go from being
like alright me it to like it a mortal
enemy Thea Baker must mean watching
thinking about suppose you wonder how it
got yeah I shown at the feedback is a
lovely like I'm the kid is great what an
amount of subs he's managed to get for
himself credit doing my from all that
he's done he started the box no no I'm
seeing any missed out there so it
might've got a t-shirt on undercard to
bottom Theo Baker's tiara Baker's scored
two most prolific goals in youtube
history one of my favorite commentary
moment
you was way over a school at Wembley
with a yeah that was a Wembley cook -
wasn't it I think maybe 110 - okay and
in casino with Spencer hoon I said come
along I got there thinking are no one
used and you'd literally already said
everything to everyone opposed and I was
like oh [__] this is my mate now on I
told everyone about this kids the next
big thing talk about well I really wish
I had on your coattails at the time he's
actually going I'm sawing this kids
amazing really I really felt like at the
time had I had a youtube label where I
could have just taken 10% of will I
could have picked back do you know what
I mean just go along me we were gonna go
for unfortunate turned out really yeah
Chris MD said that I told you but I told
him about all the drugs are back there
as well brick at all Braun's watchin
mm-hmm we're good clean lads we just
like alcohol do you member it felt like
when you hit your million I'm being
really honest it was relief I put myself
into a hole for three because I come
outside for three months I was miserable
trying a hit the one night you went out
drinking with us I remember you've been
like if I have fourteen hundred a day
for the next two that was my mentality
from May it was fun I like when people
are like you all set yourself a goal and
then dude I was obsessed and I made
myself watched a few too many Gary Vee
video
and then I watched those videos packet
I'm like their [__] videos because I was
training three videos out like a video
out every two days and it slow
it might take a week of the video it
makes good as I can I like it I enjoy it
I'm happy know I look November last year
miserable trying to hit it's just like I
remember you having that misery like
what was it like when you've seen that
I've done that when the log on poll
videos are blowing up I was just
wondering what you know neither not
genuinely hmm I was because I don't
think of anything from other people's
points of view I mean let's see what
this week yeah like what was gas
obviously it's like when you see people
because of the way there's no one would
even look at your friends will do well
but not someone who probably eternal
drop the message to our juicer and so
I'll just legend to the camp boy tell
Brian I'm asking are you [__] I mean
to be fair you did have a the fella did
have a problem back in the
but we're all going to I don't think
that problem is going away he keeps
asking Lourdes always just enough to get
a couple of so in all suitors I'm [__]
up guy and [__] every other company who
[__] didn't believe in his insult and
they can also succeed in their own time
you can succeed and just ending up in a
little cog in the story of how [__] up
I became that's what they'll succeed
where do you see your story any I see it
overdosed on something on the side of
history's up for you or me or both of us
I'm not sure both yeah I can see both of
us actually
I was probably the one that brought you
lorilynn heart I definitely want to go
out with a bang that's all I'm saying
like an actual explosion I remember that
remember completely believing it as well
really mmm how are we I was like in yes
six okay that's when wrestling's it is
most believable at that point I loved
wrestling back in the day now someone
died as a result of the 61
no that was too hot he was the all-time
best what fit the worm not Road Dogg
brian christopher the other one right
yeah yeah he's just popped at recently
as well blossom really
about wrestling aggro idolizing Stone
Cold Steve oh oh I was just like this is
the guy he was like a typical Geordie
bloke from Texas like in my head I was
like he's like so wait that rest on
mania when he was against the rock we
used to point in stone cold
I supported stone called every rock in
that always stone called I was totally
the Rocky Mountain Mike he was only used
to [__] crackles champion he had the
eyebrow if it was up where the peoples
in homes up to me
just for the record and I still take the
river in Joseph Stewart's listening yeah
when the announce that I'm commenting I
want to come out the glass so gifts do I
feel bad because I also remember the
podcast because I listened to a lot of
podcasts and I forget that you know you
almost have to like describe it via
audio what's being done so because
because when I watch it and I really
annoys me when that happens like I just
did a song called drink beer drew
smashes two beers and then tens like
pour them very high high over his head
but if you replace the beer cans
clanking - men into his face was not
what I'm going to do speaking of men who
might want to say guys hilarious man
he's big in the League of Legends
community actually he talked about
himself as disposable income and that
you would fight for me my life means
nothing I'm like this possible income
Joe Rogan damned him saying like that is
the funniest video oh wait Joe Rogan
follow Skyy yeah this guy told me about
this I was like I was like Joe Rogan
he's the reason this tables like this
now the reason I do the kickoff the
reason I do podcasting is because of Joe
Rogan I was like can I just send you of
it can you just send him one of my
videos and just be like I idolized him
zakumi
cuz you fancy mell [__] Mullen give
us a competition Williams on the lips if
he if he gets me on the Joe Rogan
podcast so now if that ever happens we
kissed I Williams on the lips if I get
on the Isle of my house what about the
fact that if you get on the podcast then
you have to kiss your Rogan I'd kiss
your I think I think I know you listen a
man with tongues is I mean unless you're
gay it's probably a really unusual
situation to find you say all right
here's one for a pocket you to go on Joe
Rogan Aesop Rock II get some advice from
Snoop Dogg and he was talking about his
relationship with dr. Dre and he said
there were times when I knew Dre just
had to step out and do his thing
and I stepped back into the darkness and
he stepped into the light like and
that's the way I see it erase you [__]
with Brian like Brian's in the light and
I'm just like that's good Brian's having
his great time but when the [__] does
universe is that my light isn't the same
as Brian solexel that's what a dim light
[Music]
thanks to me no one was watching for my
aspect of that lady remarks were on
point on that on point absolutely beyond
my point and anyways we need a great
Paul can we
I know what I'm saying is light and I'm
incredible Brian would you rather go on
Joe Rogan's podcast or him to come on
which one I would do I know which one I
do as well I know which one I would do
after Brian's answer can we say us at
the same time I could tell I could tell
you know when I've talked about me dark
times and all of this right like
genuinely when I was really really down
in that listening to Joe Rogan's early
podcasts were like what I used to like
get through the day on when I was
sitting Dawson around playing gta5 and
because of watching like that set and
all of that like being in that room with
him and being on his podcast is the way
I would I would probably I don't know
I'd already care just meeting the guys
all I really want to do but like I value
his podcast so highly to me he's the
greatest of all time like to be on his
podcast would be like an honor if that
makes sense see I I feel the same way
really yeah you want him to come on ours
yeah it was alpha-male move yeah well no
the ultimate alpha-male move is to be
like to meet you I'll go on your podcast
because because book to see after us me
though I would have him on my podcast no
that's the point is you're on his
podcast and people are watching you and
he's asking a few questions but then
you're having a conversation the best
thing you could do would be to go on Joe
Rogan's but the best Joe Rogan podcast
and not the interviews there the
conversation ones yeah that's a good one
that's one of the bed no eyeliner you've
got a note I did it for you and I think
that shows a huge personal achievement I
think that is that is that you know to
your idol to come then on to here is
Nick Shearer and then you have a Joe
Rogan to very turn the interviewer into
the it's not an interview doesn't mean
when he's
you can turn it into whatever you want
so just to put this in perspective for
the for what he's achieved on his
podcast there's something about the
status of being a guest of his yeah I
mean that's Wow well I really don't give
a [__] like I just wanna have a
conversation with the guy like cuz I
mean you realize this like what he's
done for me of course he doesn't he
doesn't even [__] know he does guys
the point I'm making is um having I'm
like I'm just literally a BTech jørgen
like I am Majed that's all I am yes
no I genuinely feel that there yeah he's
very different no I'm totally different
I just looked at what he does well and
thought how can I do similar formats of
him but in my own way yeah well now Joe
come out now do anything Joe never
picked a fight with any UFC fight as
well as I kind of do it really yeah but
he did definitely he was very honest now
you think that UFC fighters respect that
I don't have that report is from a very
prompt I would say what is his link with
UFC what do you mean I don't know I
don't watch it but like maybe he leaves
me commentator right the reason I want
to podcast do the kick off and do
commentary and all that is because like
just watching him I was like okay that's
the career I would love to have but like
me no yo Amelia I don't never do the
commentary I'd never be that
knowledgeable but doing it on YouTube is
like a cool fun alternative it's like in
my own world
Jimmy and I ya know quite differently I
think watching I think a lot of people
have said this in talking about your
million subs is watching your evolution
as a content creator
and the fact that you have decided to
change up from being a guy that people
see as someone who shouts into cameras
and now someone who can give a bit more
insight a bit more depth or those kind
of things
p-nut emitters Instagram post really so
will obviously be in the Newcastle ad
remembers when I used to do the the
Newcastle Rugby videos that everyone
used to be like I knew castles it's a
weird anyone it's a crab mentality with
as soon as you try and do anything
outspoken and be like I don't give a
[__] but anyone things like who the [__]
does this guy think he is so immediately
like a lot of people dislike me early on
from Newcastle oh yeah yeah I created
the will anything because I wanted no
one to know about the YouTube stuff like
it was all like I did your friends watch
you early on
no I told no I didn't I was you didn't
even go for another you didn't make
content that was Newcastle based either
so you kind of bypass yeah I remember
[__] again and dropped in the group
chat 10k so feel whole
so when did you get that point of view I
can tell my friends they found a 10k and
it was it was funny cuz it was like 2015
Christmas everyone found us at 10k and
then 2016 Christmas was post BG media
borrowing humblebrag so I remember how
people try it in 2050 and how people
turn it in 2016 10 K I'll be honest
though 10k seems big when you're at 10k
like that seems massive especially the
first milestone yeah yeah 10 kids like
the first most my first master I
remember very the biggest youtuber I
knew with the new was like 4050
that was it that was actually really uh
you are the Audrey of the table like
maybe a mirrorless since for like years
a Nollan before I think I mean if not
before that I remember I'm ever doing it
like it was yeah it was crazy and I
remember my friends they so I did it I
had like quite a close group of friends
at school and it was all Call of Duty
and obviously back then it was you would
commentate over the college you know one
showing face you what anyone looked like
back then because there was not like you
just wouldn't put your face on over
again videos it's not a thing what's or
things were you saying it was just me my
so the first ever video was a Tribble
isn't one place triple common trait with
me and my tumors for those too nervous
to do it by myself so I'm my two friends
jump on it this is like prepubescent
this is my voice is squeaky high I still
have some yes so good and I'm 16 and we
were did I must have been 14 15 when I
did
music ecology no I wasn't like amazing
but I was okay I figured I'm like every
school lad played call of joy I wasn't
special but yeah we did that and then
what happened was it started to filter
out throughout the school that I was
making these YouTube videos early on and
you just constantly going through the
hallways you would get these like small
references but that and and I've seen so
many kids as well to have stopped
YouTube because of what their mates
think about their videos and they don't
understand that everyone's first four
videos are [__] [__] no one has ever
banged off of like straight-up
offer one unless it was a huge mistake
that they made like they made a horrible
mother do to be uploaded a video to a
different website was like and I was
with at the time like my girlfriend was
like I call my that's you cringing right
yeah no but that's the thing it's it's
so easy to quit there as well
the temptation to go like oh yeah like
is getting my mates like realized I had
when you were starting it it wasn't as
like socially like coolers no one no
oven no no one know about you did no one
in my school watch youtube videos no it
was it was that place where you would
see funny compilations of cats yelling
off [__] that wasn't it it must be weird
for you for hopefully it's so for now
for now people just a reference I
YouTube like all the time I'm just like
this was never there but I couldn't
imagine what it's like being at school
now and starting YouTube now where it's
like super calm and do do people's mates
always go when you ask kids that what
their most desired job is no youtuber
isn't it yeah yeah like broadly I guess
a survey that went round and honestly
like I think it was like 40% of kids
between the age of like 11 and 15 say
job' youtubers yeah which is a great job
like this is working as an also you're
you publicly are going through mental
health issues so it's not only the
mental health side of things it's also
the fact that you're subject to judgment
of your mental health issues before
people even people on the outside like
self diagnose you and go like suddenly
these people become psychologists know
like he has I know he's schizophrenic or
he's whatever or he's bipolar or
whatever and actually like it's really
just that some people play a character
on behind or or whatever you look at
when I reached out to me and like DM
just saying like I need you did you yeah
[__] I was in the day I'm saying Mike I
need you to be my answer so as in like
someone important accountability as I
write like if you're [__] up
do whatever you do it whatever and I'm
everything like I was like I don't know
if I'm the best person for that spoken
to in the primary tell me after seeing
that video me like you're a good dude
like I need someone in my life who's
just going to cut the [__] like I didn't
feel qualified like I'm actually hoping
they or not
no one is I'm meeting with like some of
these like charities and stuff here cuz
I feel like I get a lot of people
messaging me more than other people
because of the [__] I speak about saying
like reaching out was and I'm always
like I'm not a guy like I don't know
what a [__] tone you know saying you
shouldn't be that's not that's not your
role but it stresses me out when you're
getting like some really kill myself and
you're like I don't you do anything but
I've got no nothing I don't know who the
[__] point these people this I'm very
like how some meetings or some charities
to be like when people message me stuff
like what do I say in but it's stranger
I mean I you know I'm a hundred percent
for like charities and things but I
think there's a reason why they don't go
to a charity because I guarantee these
people messaging you know about the
charity or I would say the majority of
them know about them but they would
prefer to message you because to fill it
video you right right and and where
there's something very cold and not
personal about I kind of feel like
that's not to say don't do you know go
for it but I mean I can see why people
message you as the perception yeah -
then huh Brian say go to a charity
probably will then help a let's say
going that's the the problem is partly
that people are think is a careless
thing you know I don't care about you
but actually it's that you're not
qualified to talk to someone who's on
this edge or all this treatment of how
yeah fully around and help them with
this and I'm like making [__] videos
about doing this quite a few fire you
from being able to talk about it like
you you've got your own life experience
and like you lived to a point where you
can speak on it but it doesn't change
that these people that have like a
script and have they're accountable for
what they do as well so it's like
there's people that job what I'm trying
to say it's like if I have someone
don't make a [__] youtube video all
right we can talk about we'll make it
we'll make it help with helpline for
that no no time soon holding you do you
make a helpline so anyway I'm it's so
footage you didn't reach up when I look
at him though I just don't I'm not
entirely sure what what you would class
because the problem with 32-bit seems is
because he spent a lot of his early
career not telling the truth now he's
gone through these issues you're not
entirely sure what the [__] going on
feel like you need epitomizes la because
if you hear the way you talk it's like
[__] reach out to a celebrity reach
out to directions like idolizes them as
if they're gods and it totally talks
about as if it's just like totally
normal to be like these are like
superior yeah really just in terms of LA
like a lot of my friend my friends
always say one either I'd love to go out
there I'd love to live out there and
then a lot my friends say I need to go
out there for two three months or
whatever and I don't mind a week out
there go for it the lifestyle there is
so different to what what is it like
because I'm very school never make
America me like it's like yeah I think I
think they just they put so much value
on social status that it's really
off-putting from me actually how many
people do you think would go there
thinking they'll be the exception to the
rule well I think that's why people go
there right it is they go there thing oh
yeah I'm you know I'm gonna make some
very friends I'm gonna break yeah and
all these sort of things and I just
think you know la and there's no we can
sit here and talk about it but honestly
the only way to truly understand it is
to actually go there and meet people and
you will understand so quickly to whip
it's a very strange person I personally
don't like it at all like you there's no
aspect of si that you like the weather
but I can get that weather somewhere
else and say no you want really the same
yeah losses you know but but to be
honest with you yes until no actually I
don't have made that sort of sweeping
statement but it's like all your
personal fear and
many other drink you know we're almost
at the end of this whole but it's like a
lot of times when you go there one of
the very first questions will be like Oh
what's your Instagram and instantly like
bluetick there you know of the back of
that you easily switch completely and so
at first still be quite like hey what's
up like this and it will either go one
way and then if someone is I mean it'll
go the complete other way and they'll be
off talking to them and you know I mean
so it's like do you value that as well
though the fact that people are very
like straight up because in other cities
you go there and people will be cool but
they're not you realize 3-4 months in
where I saw this person is actually here
for this one reason whereas in LA it's
like cool you know you know value to me
like so we don't need to be yeah yeah
okay sure I can I can I can value that
but that just means that was before I
you know if you're that person I feel
like in LA there's just so many of that
type of people it's sort of the romance
out of LA because the romance of it of
LA is that everyone was trying to make
it to the top but actually like when it
gets to a point where there's so many
people it you have to make the system
almost more efficient you know outside
about many of them I'm remembering all
the times I've spent on five right now
visualize yeah I'm like I've came to
because for example if it's just me and
my mates walking down Venice Beach we
can have a [__] quality time I don't
before I went on a trip with it was it
was well err
sugg oli white and we all went out there
honestly it was one of the best times
ever honestly it was truly one of the
best trips ever but what it was very
much oh and we'll Derbyshire as well and
it was just all of us and we had a
[__] banging time but that was
because we kept it like that and we just
went and had fun and yeah we would meet
and bump into other people and we had a
same time because the place is actually
fun it's the attitude and the
social-climbing that is just so so
apparently very top I also think the
difference with you is like you don't
look like everyone else so you have
these exceptional rules where people
will treat you differently right it's
true though I Brian
like double like if you add me to you
then brands that well if guy and then
you are bigger so people look at you and
they evaluate if anyone Elliot would
recognize as now that I've had more
important you must have gained a massive
American audience to be honest we'll get
into those analytics logins you're kind
of going this is how you do even Rob
blue like four times a day I think like
I went through this stage where you're
looking at social baiting and one day I
actually I went on my laptop and I
blocked it this was probably a year and
a half to two years ago maybe two years
ago I think it was and I was it you just
like this [__] will be the reason why I
go [__] insane
ya know because honestly it's a numbers
game about you recently I was like a few
months ago you got a video that did harm
any of you and you punch the tables look
it's like you it's so it's kind of that
it's kind of not because I every single
video I put everything I can make it as
much as good as I can't do it's like
okay it's a body of work as well but
then you're like okay this one's been
crippled for views and stuff
and it's just like literally it's all
because I love it so much but then it's
also all I cared about at the point
where everyone at this table like part
of what I [__] got like I've totally
saying like cow ISM Callum Willard
probably the two guys who made the most
iconic podcasts know without a doubt why
do you think we've made the million
progress
we only UK that was the best podcast
right that when we last for those who
don't know we did a podcast another you
said a lot of things that we weren't
supposed to say in whatever about yellow
people think oh I can see and that was I
think that was the first podcast where
UK youtubers at sat down and got pissed
and just said whatever was on their mind
and they that I Ramone I played I was
like [__] me like we've done some that
other people haven't done yet like I
guess in America I might have been done
before there but not really well I don't
know since you know the thing is the you
kids a lot tighter knit yeah it's tight
sometime I feel it's a lot so it hits a
bit harder yeah since we did that like
mom's basement whatever and the people
have started doing a few of those but
everything that podcast that reward just
be like did you know there was a man
well we're on the [__] roads me you
was so pissed in the end I remember okay
this is gonna sound weird but I wouldn't
change it I still would not change in
like I'm being a bit I would not change
it unless anyone you've offended is
watching very quickly after it went live
or watching no but I wouldn't because
he's one of those things and I'm still
here you know it like I said before the
podcast started I got a lot of messages
from people saying be careful of like
what you say and stuff at the end of the
day it's why hurry bring hurry hurry
come on such a state the last time me
and how easily demonstrate last time I
went over your birthday yeah we call it
hurry come on the podcast he won't know
army career will be over yeah yeah
we know me and Georgie are still gonna
do a podcast aren't right we're doing a
special podcast Oh in fact I'm so will
you wanna be part one you absolutely do
not want to be part of this which one oh
you see when the podcast where you oh
yeah yeah yeah we want to get baked
Alvar no Lawrence will do that I thought
you were that's probably watching I did
yes this way Snoop Dogg wears a lot of
out he does you know
okay fair enough well then I say we
should just get really [__] who else
can we get for that though Mary when
when changes sign to fight Logan with me
and you oh and you were testing sequence
let's go Jordi's podcast to get big I'm
gonna freak we're up oh right more like
organize the whole thing's got the
[__] rupture would have been [__]
well we still need to do I've gotten two
for it now he can because he oh geez
were out yeah Lawrence if anything
Lawrence is the pakura
I feel strawberry it just should [__]
be linked below
I mean it's been legalized in Canada
America we are showing out with on this
podcast telling us to invest in weed
because it's only gonna get legalized
more and more place investment
opportunity of a lifetime because the
end of a black market yeah we've never
seen anything like her owner the company
invest in current icon was called has
invested in marijuana like that's crazy
yeah it's legal in my home what what hmm
well in my home your home is my house
yeah the higher you get particularly the
fifth floor which for have you got in
your house my Familia completely leg day
you end up I can't but I have everyone
knows I have a dodgy knee I just can't I
was up feeling when you're playing
lately it's been good at a training
session on Wednesday and it feels by the
way we love it by the way yes before
before before but I was meant to bring
both your table I've completely forgot
to bring you soon the next so sure cuz
what
do you know the thing that I love right
so originally my feet is still are
interested we hope we won't know what we
need is it a big leaf on the front it's
sort of like a yeah it's like I might
believe this lost weight so the best
thing was right EXO FC is a thing it's a
real thing it's real we're gonna we're
gonna kill the world honestly we're
gonna be shite but as long as we've got
the sauciest kit that's all I care so
although I what was interesting was so
there's a point where I was captain of
EXO FC purely because I was available
and then one day under sauciest sponsors
got involved and when Lawrence doesn't
have enough followers can will be the
captain of EXO FC please now that's for
me first no they asked for Brian I've
said I'm doing the shoot of funny
Stevens a bit yes Steven is available so
if you had during your time you've been
a youtuber one one one and and no one
knows about her no you live quite a
public life so you you you Instagram
story but when it comes to like girls
that have you won't see any of that
stuff on my insta story because in my
opinion don't eat you don't one you
don't need to and and if I'm perfectly
honest with you I think it's a so it's a
recipe for disaster
eventually things get twisted yeah and
I've seen it happen so more when they
turn on you know when they turn on you
but you know you do you know what girls
are obviously a lot more sensitive if
they're not used to the limelight if
they're not used to comments calling
them a fat [__] or all that sorta it's
like it's just unfair to throw someone
into it it was about a whole perfect
they are
getting no benefits from this it's like
you're part of the [__] you get all
the ship it without the good bits of
[__] okay as you're ten a lot of the
out of be held to a social standard
which maybe you wouldn't do as a normal
person offline but so some couples do it
where they partner in so they'll they'll
make it obviously some people look at
very long way ahead and think we'll we
you know I'm not always gonna be a gamer
I'm not always gonna be this kind of
right so in the future I'm gonna be a
lifestyle I kind of Lance where the
girlfriend comes in for them is like no
pictures not for everyone
I'm not I'm not selling out because some
if the other person buys into it then
that's totally fine all these power
couples where like girls like a bad
[__] when she's like she called Nando's
so I'm not Alfie and Zoe recently seen
the pictures of jay-z and Beyonce in
concert jay-z looks like a skeleton of
used to look like Beyonce and jay-z
looks like looks like she's gone out
[Music]
I've heard that won't be the first
person Rios all I'm saying really
on the other photo happens mr. McGregor
no they were just flirt no I fit no oh
no I saw that I'm not having that cuz I
think I honestly think do you know if
there's one sort of celebrity couple
that I'm really rooting for it actually
is Conor McGregor now because I really
think a look is hold on for a second
though the reason
can I just debunked that just for a
second so this is why Ryan nice sitting
on a movie set this is one the weirdest
stories I'm going to tell like I'll sort
of run the like so out of nowhere we get
a phone call from very evening producer
Brian gets a movie I drug lauridsen's
yeah we got a movie called from when you
should do that a producer ring to me it
goes there I'm on a move I'm on a set
right now and the direct that's just
said that we need someone who looks like
a serial killer
I thought loads make a good young Harold
shipment for the record any make an old
Harold shipment before the record he was
a doctor who killed a lot of people
anyway they've got very depressed
important a lot of the point is there's
a movie being made with who was the
carry old Gary Oldman was Gary Oldman in
the movie anyway it's a big movies be
nice have will shoot some enthusiasm
it's millions subscribe so anyway where
is this room and it turns out there's a
lot of other actors in there some of the
more models yeah one of them
no well one of them was a guy who was
really a very camp man
Rory Aurora's dress yeah he was a nice
guy
I actually thought so this man so this
man walks out
this man walked out and what can only be
described as the most part of a [__]
suit apart from the [__] hat right all
the way down to the poop okay
I don't know that for a fact he's seen
it's much bigger so the point is that he
walks out how many go and Brian dine
starts having a conversation with this
guy right
I'm Brian talked about Conor McGregor's
through Rita Ora and this guy denies
that Rita Ora was close with Conor
McGregor to such a point where I begin
to think that was more than he did in
the [__] usual war sauce March right
I know I [__] up right he's shouted at
me a lot I didn't know he did fuchal you
did quite like those boots were
beautiful will I mean they made me play
absolutely show I'm Joe Rogan I'm Joe
Rogan I've got me on table I've got me
on big wooden table Selfridges gonna
have a [__] field produce your
bigness now I'm messing the other day I
said you're a genius mate
congratulations he texts me back thanks
dud no dude couldn't even complete the
word for me God thanks dad PewDiePie
followed me Andy I need made a video
with me in it yeah I like feel I like
you moderator I would have no one else I
kind of like he's the moat he's the most
unlikely biggest youtuber it's like
[__] YouTube's dad
PewDiePie sense of humor isn't perfect
he's the most sarcastic [__] ever and I
love he's also pretty well for where I
feel like he's quite a lot of stuff from
other people as well as he's like he's
just the problem he says the N word I
like it's a big problem yeah but I like
the fact that I win
he defended me against Logan and he was
like he's not hurting anyone you know
he's just gonna do it but who cares he's
not that is the nicest thing I have ever
heard anyone explain Logan Pole he's an
idiot
but he's not hurting anyone you should
be thanking him that's like a compliment
for your standard like how you were the
true Gordie yeah Logan first rung me up
he called me Gordie accordingly can we
put on the title again what the question
is before because you rang mitten like 9
o'clock at night right and we had yeah
okay I knew this was going down who told
you I'm voters the inside nobody knew it
was gonna happen and then I got a
message saying you know it's looking 90%
there's a battle be a phone call that
goes down if everything goes smoothly
I'm saying he needs some credit though
like seriously because in terms of
YouTube events any YouTube event he is
put on has been top [__] tier in
terms of upload you look upload that was
very well cholesterol take good job he
does a good job he stresses [__] when he
does it can we just say Stuart loves me
because he knows he can rely on me
that's why he loves me so I love Stuart
for that we faced
Mary Stuart Jones has had sex with more
peep more women and maybe people maybe
we should just broaden our peoples and
all of us regardless whoever's the real
chummy know of us was in the word and
the words of shun and brings with all
chance we're all chance your number is
high what's your number
there is no know your step into this
table with saying can we just say I just
want to put this on me I don't know my
number and I do and I don't mean that in
a oh I forgot it a year ago I'm trying
to say I've never ever given a [__]
about like I don't think anyone once
once you hit a certain number I I'm just
interested in good experiences right can
I change the topic of the sentence so
often they're so clear you know the
numbers I've just been this but they're
okay we should move on now no I
definitely don't know the number swear I
swear the guy no I swear I could tell
you within my political I think I
stopped counting with about 21 even the
age 21 or the number 21 bit of yeah what
about you will I'm in love Culp so I
wouldn't you know what I'm surprised
that wills admit that he's in a
relationship with Mia after the cherry
much yep
and then Carl [__] snapshots around
the room so it's so we went back to your
house
Chris MD his girlfriend yeah cowlicks
his girlfriend and that punched me and
me some
he's got a girl's got a sister of course
a girlfriend of course it's the boy that
mandates Jersey milk is not having a go
the thing is all with your videos right
you take the piss out of everyone
yeah except is that does that not make
you like a bit worried about like
putting her on the spot what about the
Instagram because her Instagram any
problem is what's the word
it's like model II type pictures though
isn't it yeah tumblr tumblr esque
definitely when guys who follow you come
on and watch your look at your
girlfriend's pictures yeah nearly
does that bother you the comedy comment
I see it's not the guys it's the girls
it's everyone with Minter and their
names nothing bothers him there's
nothing he's not bothered me about it
what's it like being in a relationship
no but you haven't had a serious serious
thing I feel like but to me doesn't
count
can I just sit because I just want to
say something cause I've got a million
subscribers right sorry to me this is
your first like serious serious
relationship on YouTube where I'll be
like this might be no since I met you
every girl yeah I you've enrolled me to
a few girls but this is the first girl
where I've been like oh she could be the
one here chinnu I'm saying the one but
yeah it's the first she could be there
she could be one here we're big fans I'm
actually you know what she seemed like
such a sweet girl Lawrence is more into
her than I are
no I'm the biggest champ if I friends
were absolutely not you [__] his
girlfriend you horrible what kind of
friend are you honestly if he dies in a
plane crash
you wouldn't shagger you should be
picking up the slack does anyone even
look after your girlfriend when you're
dead it should be Lawrence McKenna
Turner it's the kind of thing that Brian
and I have had very what feel like real
discussions about when Brian dies what's
gonna happen to me channel yeah we just
say can I just put this on oh right if I
die
Lawrence inherits everything and then
distributor we need someone to chip in
and contract that you makes you have to
be around we need someone to play the
womanizing pisshead and I do feel like
Karl
I wish the appropriate to tick by sorry
what could he grow a beard somewhere Tim
Allen basically knocked Santa Claus off
the roof
if Brian dies you slowly become 10
stolen on yeah and everyone's like
what's happening the other foot cream
with everything yeah that was a sad
movie wasn't it really was released
about diabetes people are being
twittering or saying [__] we should talk
about
I've not listen to a [__] thing
you've said all day how long am I being
like who can neck white light this is a
three-hour special office I feel like
we've hasn't even scratched the surface
Lud's I've got a lot of drama and beef
that we all right
no we need a customer sorry cuz I'm
getting late record for four oh the guy
who has two hours the guy who owns you
the most come on rich [__] you
ever make some friends who if you're not
doing anything tomorrow night shout me
we'll go to the park it both of you
this not you because you're trying to me
into a [__] girlfriend's dad yeah but
everyone else are you worried about me
it no dad no [__] chin him now I'm
serious though what you like okay you're
your mama does adorable can I just say
showed out the big shots for signing the
petition for getting obviously she's a
very classy woman she was two she was
two glasses deeper you know I'm having a
popper Will's mum yeah but we were at
the sidemen match and and my mom goes I
fancy him cats Geordie in it fancy him
and I was it she like you what mom no
she went can it can we get a picture and
I was like yeah just go and ask him
start them I can't do it she and keep in
mind she as anyone for a vote and it
adjourn if she comes out I just I just
she genuinely fancies for the record of
a thing field for the record as mom's
the same like she walks in the room and
goes I just casually wander over to this
table you could take your pick apart
from mine
is that why do you not just bang loads
of milsat honestly for me I am
appreciative man you know I mean I
respect the wrinkles the thing is with
women though I think they look at me and
they're know sort of what they're buying
in the liver a lot of people feel right
like they go through life and they don't
meet Brian before they meet their
husband
a lot of women wish there's a mess Ryan
a bit of rough and ready yet they've
called wish they met Brian before they
met her husband is sort of the last it's
a bit like when you've gotten to go to
Alton Towers and you think you know
before we leave I'll go one last time on
the nervously on nemesis Brian is before
a woman gets Brian his nemesis before a
woman gets all right so if they've been
married for one they see Brian they
think what I've been to Gulliver's
Kingdom but I'd love to go to Alton
Towers Drayton Manor Park was good but
that big dicker dipper looks really good
I wish I'd gone on that before I
remember what I've done a couple of
other ladies and can I just ask you
what's the oldest person you've ever had
sex with sixty oh no way that it's not
sexy there's no way no it's obviously
not see I would I reckon it oldest bird
you shagged this 38 whoo and so for a
couple of drinks okay but you've
definitely what you've definitely had is
a point where you've thought this person
was older than you would have found
attractive would be the political of two
legit I have to say right like I don't
need a monetize the art carpet
there's four sis white males like
obviously the women the women in their
20s or whatever the things are a bit
everything's just good it looks good on
them children I mean their bodies are
really in peak physical condition bright
as Lawrence would say if he was
commentating a boxing event I challenged
I hey they're really lovely behind the
scenes but I think there's a a woman
who's in his where it's not as much as
it used to be expensive
what is this analogy and what's it
becoming I don't understand where I'm
gonna like a Ferrari
[__] right this car run trying to say
right is as a man when you're [__] a
girl in their twenties right like you
feel like it's sort of your privilege
woman in her late thirties it's her
privilege Jim she's grateful for that
you're sort of if anything you feel like
are you I'm the pretty one
I'm the pretty one
I'm clear can I just say I'll clear the
table my well pour from Carl my work
here is done but the thing is it's in a
different I've got a birthday when we
all just I'll say just down the road
almost [__] just down the road at 24
that's really so if anyone wants to go
girls birthdays are always the best yeah
I had everyone about they got better as
well no no it was a bit of a cop-out was
a bit last-minute everyone you play a
good like center of attention and a
party you handle it well oh thank you I
appreciate that lemonade please
all right no I do appreciate because I
actually do I don't like being the
center of attention I like to talk a lot
I want to be grown in like a [__]
snake snake that's a modern that's a
modern oh yeah I haven't really I feel
like you'd paint yourself in the boat
like yeah that's fine venom venom is not
good I had briefly actually just talked
about cows a 30-minute long news show I
thought I use the best boat video
currently it's funny you say that and
not to literally suck the [__] out of
your dick but it I thought your next
week on the internet was [__] quality
and not suspension and not to men
and not to mention one that you called
it deny being drop way we were being
dropped him being drop and - it's for
you edited that yeah and I thought I was
[__] brilliant I thought it was
really fun the whole I didn't did she at
that point I knew nothing like Manuel
saying false or true
Harry's really struggling to come to
terms with the fact that he's becoming
feel good the worst thing about it is if
you're struggling to become hurry back
quite a built kid door like he's
naturally quite like if you're
struggling becoming deliverer who does
that yeah and point I think if he
actually lifted weight so he'd be like
no no no so yet may he's incredibly
strong there was a time where he went to
the gym for like two or three months
with none of this [__] [__]
around him and he bowed out honestly
this guy he could become huge
what so I I commented on the first one
we cook and I remember looking and
thinkin you're actually a little hard
bastard you were yeah in the inner me in
like if you actually like trained and
all are in like tough things I was
actually very impressed with how you
went through a couple of people I was
and he was issued right in front of me
me and both saw the same video with the
same views we saw all in one spot and he
was actually just two steps in front of
me half three weirdly in the group top
before it's like whoever has rice gum
will get the because year yeah I saw
weirdly I've never met someone with the
same name as major looks more different
than me than rice come both Brian's
Sochi games Brian with a wider
I mean Ryan Lee bright for the purpose
of this video he's price coming true
Geordie had the same name
he was born in Vegas what yeah live in
Vegas I couldn't have you been I've
never been to America I don't I want to
go up there's a lot of money maybe you
don't need a lot of money but maybe you
just need to be fully invested you need
to be fully invested in with Vegas trees
what I want to do the bucks I played it
but a lot of people's disappointment as
they have to explain every step of a
certain way so craps really intrigues me
and like craps is put in the microwave
but craps is like a really fun look at
ya ha what's hard this chance though
it's hard but it's like no no just in
fact I I struggled very much to come to
go for it so sorry craps right yeah
you're playing craps you're rolling the
dice have you ever had a moment where
you rolled the dice and everyone around
the table I need to let you know I've
only ever played it twice and I'm very
pleased so that you're talking to me
like I played it 2 more times nice yeah
whereas I've heard about it recently and
I thought wow I want to play craps craps
as movies will do that to you movies pop
culture and too many bloody Ocean's
eleven New York oh [__] they don't say
great Ocean's eleven come on let's talk
about iconic movies yeah incredible
incredible incredible amazing film ask
you a question right Brad Pitt yeah
which one would you be
or you daddy or should have Brad Pitt
I'm Brad Pitt anyone thinks that Brad
Pitt
no but do you know I I want to just
quickly go on it give me one minute to
chat here absolutely different
I'm fed up a [__] superhero me
I hate on I'm gonna superhero movies I
went to watch Incredibles [__] moon
on the hill that'll be writing right
Incredibles - and keep in mind yeah I
watched it and I thought it was a good
movie I thought all right at the same
time this is a movie that I should be
blown away with what - yeah and every
seven-year-olds no no but I'm being
serious lava is because I've seen so
many superhero movies everything feels
the same the comedy is exactly the same
spider-man everything seems a [__]
same I need an inception I need an
interstellar I need something that gets
me [__] going I'm super in the setup
blew my [__] money put me in a
three-day period of depression where I
sat in my [__] room in the dark room
thinking about what the [__] was going
on wonder if anyone's pushing any it was
[Music]
just like what special yeah but anyways
what I'm trying to say guys is that I'm
done with all these Hollywood
blockbusters get me an inception it does
anyone have any movie recommendations
lately and what honestly make me think a
thought provoking I genuinely call me in
to let people go to the cinema to see
that Gary Oldman movie and there's me
and you so you anywhere you want so I'm
like so this girl's like I can't give
the pretext of the movie because I don't
know how much I want to say about
anybody in the room and I'm like you you
[__] [__]
and I'm just like if I'm gonna say one
thing in a Hollywood movie I want it to
be [__] [__]
he's a Hollywood it's got Hollywood
stars in it to the point where you go
wow that's
I play I play a serial killer we all
play serial killer
okay I think he's a quality circular I
think you are assigned almost to
stereotypically they needed so there was
a lie you would deal me a grammar county
I wanted to avoid the typecasting of
Brian so I went along with him one of
those garyvee like pictures of me like
and then there was like a brain there
was a model in there there was a
pregnant woman in there there was like a
suit in there certain tiny the idea is
you don't know who's I'll say this Brian
and the model flirting outrageously
between takes what did you shag her I
didn't do any she was flirting with
Brian and Brian was I'll just say can we
just see how it right yeah okay yeah all
right all right fair enough
Brian didn't hope with anyone but she
was flirting so outrageously with you to
the registry the point where other
people in the group were going looking
at Brian like what has he got some sort
of gold dick or something that she it's
it's true but I'm not a doctor so is
trying to stay in character so I wasn't
talking to anyone imagine you being so
[__] to the point where like anything
outside of it would just annoy him yeah
like if it wasn't about the particular
movie I love Robbie Williams uzuki
Robbie stayed in touch to refer never
gets into oh we could do that never gets
in touch what little egg so I think
Robbie would turn over actual you know I
exercise I bet you love Stephen tries
Instagram and we'll Ernie has a square
head yes I saw
lose her I'd say that was one of the
most surreal moments of my life was
having Robert walk into his house
welcome into his house and him going we
can't just say hi we've got a hug it out
now I was like having lunch with it I
stood him up though aye aye captain with
so the best thing was that we got to
spend some really quiet time with him
where it's like you never really get
time with people when you don't really
like when you're trying to make friends
with someone and you're trying to like
chat to them about things
Brian was late and so I was like this is
perfect we can be friends with have a
learner's like absolutely those kind of
friends sitting around just like having
lunch with their boys number chatting
about it Brian does like Logan Paul
number I've never been a bit has it on
[__] sweat much will I'll tell you
one thing Brian slapped his head chute
recently when he got given an XXL said
in front of everyone meaning [__]
Stephen Troy get you maverick
[Music]
this doesn't run this car already that
was so that was brief it was a brief 15
quid Lord you made a funny joke when he
said that you might and I thought that
was unfair you bring a PR team into
YouTube beef you're [__] cheating
[__] team I think everyone knows you
had a lot of [__] advice in that
video there's no doubt about it I mean
almost advice at a point where you have
a team full of people that are concerned
about your performance enhancing drugs
in the fights we use a PR team in
YouTube because you deleted and
disqualify me just keep me commenting
get rid of it just deserve to be get me
a PR team is cheating brides looking at
me like I don't know what to say there's
one no I'm cool just text him after
we're saying will says some things about
you but I disagree disagrees but the
thing is JJ did another PR team JJ has
this
imagine having hurry up now the one
thing I've got from that chat with him
on the phone is that he's actually like
he's not as ignorant as what people
think he is like no no but I think I
think everyone knows that it's the same
with Jay Jay in the sense that the
on-screen camera persona but JJ is not
completely different to his on screen it
from me is was an exaggerated like an
extremely exactly and I think this is
the volume curve right it's from 4 to 11
yeah that's actually what it is on both
people I know can we not 1 don't just
keep very much there's so many things I
disagree about Logan what he did but
then again looking back to what JJ and
from what I know now he shouldn't have
done but back then you're in your early
20s you're famous you're rich like how
the [__] you gonna keep a level head at
that point it's not even though it's
about understanding and knowing yeah
it's I'm not defending that I'm just
saying everyone gonna [__] up in that I
don't know if they'd [__] up in the same
way I would have just [__] up in
another way probably nobody's even just
when they're young you make so many
mistakes but do not reflect me as to why
I am now and I look back and I see like
you know where all these celebrities
where all the Twitter come and [__] like
that you said that five years ago you're
also probably you're in a mood wave
maybe you've just watched South Park or
something oh I'm in a playful offensive
mood I'm gonna tweet something that
people would be like this is funny like
people say silly things in jest but that
some people you you can look at them and
be like I know your character like I
know you're not a person there are other
people you looking at me like you're a
piece of [__] and I'm not saying like
write them off forever but there are
degrees I
I think if it's one of those things like
look there's there's an example for five
years ago three years ago one year ago
now right there's a [__] trend
whereas out yeah but if it's like five
years ago three years ago and clearly
right here you woke the [__] up and you
realize alright fine you know what like
people do change and I you know I think
that it they grow up they change their
views that loads of stuff and it's
happened to me life expire hope it's
happened to a lot of other people as
well but it's just one of those things
you can't jump at someone and it's such
a shame because we're really at the
start of something where you're gonna
look in 10 20 years and those same
people are gonna have it but 10 times
harder than what we have it now because
everything from the age of 12 to 13 when
they open their Twitter account they're
gonna have [__] all the way to when they
documented whereas I maybe had it from
1516 G's because that may be showing you
though like the the fact that actually
you don't need to document every one of
your opinion but when you're 10 11 12 13
14 you like it doesn't matter if it is
in a different way like you're forming
your opinions you're like you've got to
be able to play around with ideas when
you're 12 and 13 so like having weird
ideas at that age or having negative
ideas when you're that you can look at
when you're 20 through you it's all part
of getting to that point
and even even me at 20 even me at 23 now
I look at my 23 now yeah 23 now I even
mean looking back at 20 year old right
here so would you 20 rolled me which a
lot of people would deem as like quite
mature like 20 you know and I'm like
this guy knows [__] what are you on
about you know I mean and it's
embarrassing so I'm there I'm there to
say aah laughs it's cruel man I really
you know I'd probably have judge people
on their past but I now more than ever
I'm so aware of trying not to do that
there's anyone around this table who has
judged someone to a huge degree in their
met them and then had me experienced
them in real life it's you right
alfie deyes was a classic exam and I'm
not throwing that and you're facing her
now like you're an idiot
he was a classic example I thought of
you
she was an [__] like I thought it was
a totally different person what a year
did you think he was a Tory though I'm
not by the way he's not at all I love
these I'm not worried I'm not a Tory I
just say there are people who take him
now who aren't in our circles who still
find that clip and still go this is what
is a terrible thing to know what I want
to say about Alfie is what I look at his
content now and I'd like Alfie as a
person now I think he's a nice kid but
all of the criticisms I said about
Alphaeus nothing about how I felt like
him wandering round Brighton recording
what he was doing wasn't maximising this
potential if anything now I look at his
videos where he's going Twitter decides
what I do for a day
Instagram besides what I do for a day
I'm like you told me on that podcast
that you were just gonna film your life
and that's the reason behind what you
were doing and now by the fact that
you're telling people to decide what you
do for day I feel like he's really out
of ideas and it's showing that his chunk
the way his channels are is right and I
don't mean this in a nasty way - because
I like Alfie and I my criticism to him
at the time when because he was one of
the biggest in the UK when I made those
criticisms and now I feel like he never
leveled up and I feel like that
that's why his channel is what it is
right now to replace that though do you
not think that maybe he looks at that
and thinks that looks like fun like I'll
get in on that not in a think that was
naive and that's why he ended up doing
the one pound challenge which was a I
thought that was quite blown out
proportion for Alfie I felt you know I
really you know it's a mistake of a
video to make of his but it's also I'm
known Alfie enough to know that he he's
not the sort of guy to go and like
intentionally disrespect and you look
back at it and you go yeah that was
pretty [__] [__] why are you
looking at and go like but it was stupid
I actually thought of the apology videos
we've seen on YouTube
Alfie apology for the one pound video
was probably the most genuine apology I
mean he literally goes historian what is
[__] stupid like this was a stupid
videos man
you could see them what the [__] I don't
know I I don't appreciate you saying
about the Instagram controls my life
because I'm so all you know what's a
good that is a good idea though I do
actually quite like that as an idea
sighs you don't we go in Europe next
week yeah but can I just say though can
I just say white is with alfie is my my
problem with him was I was saying you
should be bright like Bronco and he was
like I just want to record me life
that's all I want to do and my point is
is by telling everyone Instagram decide
your life for a day
that's not recording your life that's
contrived like pre you're coming from
can I also say though it goes against
the whole basis of his channel they just
record my life is if he doesn't play the
game do you think he can't contain
always a very rich guy this may be a
silly question but you understand if he
doesn't play the game then maybe can't
continue to record his life to the same
level because he has financial
constraints if he doesn't play the game
some extent like we're all we're all
subject to some rules about performing
on YouTube not no one is really exempt
from taking part in the trends or taking
part in the half to go with the trend
that how to some extent so that part of
his life because he's a youtuber does
that make sense to some degree anyway
but I think III think it's one of those
things like he's just so the idea itself
one pound living on Hanah is fine but he
just he just he basically there you go
no you it's in that video we would have
got away with that we let's be honest
right let's be honest cause everything
breaks it I think what we're all in a
grandchild
it's alfie is easy pickins he sets
himself up for it as well along and I
think I think it's hard because it is so
easy to talk
like when we talk about easy targets
alfie is really one of those low hanging
fruit he's also so unlikely to reply so
you're very you're you're really just
you're really just left with a mic drop
no matter what you do because alfie is
very unlikely to close on you one
question I would ask you is though
because so I quite a few of my family
members don't watch YouTube and so when
I have a mixed family members where it's
like the 14 to 18 and 19 guys with the
30 year old people like why does that
matter why is that an important thing
how much I don't understand what's going
on in your life you guys are silly and
I'm on the telly because I swear no
anyone in your family refreshing your
Muslim media Wow taxi drivers your
brothers the time was going on and and I
just going on I can't keep because the
question they're the same so how do you
make all this or think is it good money
all this or stuff I can't be honest so
I've come up with this entire uber
persona where
and ego get in okay
night out with the boys it's for a
female so what was that what are you
what do you do for your job just
studying I'm just I'm just studying at
the moment Oh what are you studying what
my study our film about the film and TV
people you've had in your car previously
that's really yeah yeah no yeah so how
much money from revans born I'm a final
year literary would just I'm really
fighting me the OSHA foreign accent yeah
fine I'm now looking at Lauren and I
would love a parallel universe to watch
Lawrence be an uber driver video with no
views
Oh Oh
if you promoted it if you promoted video
when it comes out talk to me on a real
level Twitter will do nothing for your
views recommended only people give a
[__] about is is them ones where they
finish a video they click on the next
tab but only realizing I really did I
just wanted the moral support if I
disagree anything any of them any of the
big boys who's your best performer
Stephen when everyone's jealous of their
friends performing I'm like George bang
so I'm just [__] George in my tummy
George's actually said he wants to come
on the TJ podcast you [__] chaperone
and we'll do it be really good welcome
what we have to just be a very good we
just have to know George is interesting
what we do is we make him play a game
we're still at snowboard down a mountain
is what I realized is that George was up
the she's literally top three in the UK
calmly what is that you say okay it's
fine it's not interesting but like the
guy is not shown his face and say
nothing real-time what do you say easy
top three wat dog [__] top three views a
month
who else Harry Caray yeah you want to
dance EDM
you want to talk PewDiePie mamillus is
on a level that he's not on
if you think oh no no you shoot journey
dancing tbonz what five years horizon--
been four times okay
and growing okay in terms do you think
you will I I think that's why people you
know I think that's why people say their
man is a song it reminds you really the
old-school YouTube like he's playing
some wack-ass [__] game change it
about someone and it's funny he's got
good one-liner it's dude do I think he
can do on a podcast not for me boss
[Music]
because videos are [__] quality and I
love what you're saying and just to be
clear everyone at this table likes me me
this videos so that's very different on
a podcast over a three-hour period
1996 podcast under the belt and God
knows how many kickoffs it is different
because he's gone off the top of the
head a few times that we have met him he
has actually been quite a chatty guys
good it tolls to George you go good
podcast I've only met him when he
statement first exactly same Tim I
respect that US team in our entire
sterling was fever still steaming
steamin with Steve Steven was at the he
made a lot of people jokes again you
know every time I go drinking receiving
someone he was chatting up a girl who
was a pretty girl she used to go out
with a youtuber who's well-known
we're sorry you start again
last time you one way to say again sorry
mr. C well as a girlfriend it's calm
wait there's even a joke he didn't at
this point so at this point Stevens did
another girlfriend shutting up what's on
him yeah oh yeah she's been on my lie
detector what's the game
oh we know the game what is the so first
person on a thunk for the million subs
is a diver who I used to go diving with
called Dave who told me to reload the
male Ranger run when I do it the first
time yes I pulled it like 20,000 views
cuz I was like lots of people are gonna
say this and mean life is gonna be over
in New Castle right Dave the diver so
sure that's a real name then Jimmy
Conrad who gave me a job at all
imagine that show Jimmy Conrad how great
for you for Jimmy Conrad supporting an
obscure English no don't talk and cook
my nightly then bought kick to beheld
they suck me from there but what if they
enough so you got to thank him for that
and I mean thankful sucker doesn't give
me the motivation to push on to end up
with more subscribers then obviously
well more anyways so continue on to the
next building football republic they
took me on wood at a key time a producer
called Adam bolt woods sorta head hood
is me I mean we don't have to cut him
too much it was the talent was clear he
then put me alongside a little-known
youtuber called Lawrence McKenna
so we we were then doing some [__]
little skype videos of me and him you
saw the laugh together we didn't really
know each other and we realize that the
[__] before we went live was a lot
funnier than the actual video is that
but like two people from either end of
Skype one and put it this way I know the
Skype chats at that time I family all
over the world
we weren't even looking at each other
because I was looking at a camera and
you're looking at a camera and all you
could see was a camera of a huge room
with loads of cameras and load lights in
and we just be making David Brent
references back and making each other
laugh like within the first moment and
we go Paul would leave that in and bolt
would um I'm gonna say some very
offensive
for years I think 2015 16 so when a boat
words like you know third musketeer
between us we're talking about first
generation YouTube waves then he was the
first generation of YouTube waves of the
football a lot of YouTube channels busy
or him big-time to to of the big each if
one of them's massively [__] up and
the other one is just shut out knew
where bolt would for giving me a shot on
there and putting me with you then
moving forward just as football republic
decided to suck me because people are
drug problems in there basically another
company took me on
who cares who they were there was a guy
in that company called Marvin who I
brought he believed in me he was a month
he formerly worked for Man City a
YouTube channel but he's a really good
dude and he basically championed me to
the company in saying let's give this
lad what he wants at the time what I
wanted was a comedy appear for my
podcast oh because I couldn't afford to
pay studio time and everything so I'll
only say with you if you give me a
podcast marvin told them give him a
podcast so shout out and from that point
and at the time there was only one
person I wanted to do it with
I remember that phone called you
remember that phone call where we were
working out what we do like how that
would work yeah and you got and
essentially we were pitching to each
other like houses
work and we didn't really know each
other not to the extent we know each
other now not so the sort of feeling the
other one out like so what would you do
if you did a podcast and you were like I
did this and I was like actually sounds
pretty I'm in your adaptions I remember
you talking to me being like I wanna
start a podcast yeah it'd be like
literally like I want to start this and
you know oh [__]
cuz I known you for three years before
like I know of you for the time before
then being like [__] that's a big
adoption where people like you Joella
Spence Alec will you come on your
podcast when I make it and well not
merely a lot of youtubers came on the
podcast at a time a lot of people were
saying make it into 5 to 15 minute clips
and upload it as clips yeah so do the
whole podcast on iTunes but then put the
video of like a 10 minute highlight reel
of the actual podcast or Big L the
company that said yeah we rolls on
iTunes but the point is when we made the
podcast a lot of youtubers turned up for
us
Kyle free is he being one of them so
thanks to Carl huge the sidemen ksi will
Ernie sure Joella Stephen tries Chuck me
all allowed to turn up Jimmy Jimmy
Connor again
I mean he was on a contract I'm the
nicest broke I probably but you're
taking one thing I realized is like
community in the UK like American
youtubers don't really have that
community vibe but we we have that way
and I realized how much I needed people
to come out and remember the remedy Cook
was starting just before start the
podcast and I went and I wanted to play
in the Wembley Cup and Spencer course
was nominate you should be commentator
and that was why I end up commenting in
the first one pick up so shout out a
space I thought having the faithfulness
to comment it and yeah only cup though
it's fine we always wanted to do a live
show and you brought in people like Pete
who people behind the cupboard or serine
SP apps
I'm sure for a little woman you called
me and said there's some people looking
for presenta be the presenter and I was
like yeah why not and we turned up one
Saturday and were like yeah it was a
[__] line show but we ended up doing a
good life show which was what all in my
show yeah and then we brought in once
quickly in what was that life with the
[__] live show when you were small yeah
what for Chelsea I do offer chills like
when he didn't have many subs at the
time and I was like let's get will any
involved well I think you must have like
25 case bullshitting myself outside of
what for Chelsea how mental is that that
I'd ever seen you've got a charged them
though don't take nothing pretty no I
shot myself in the day before I let you
out darlin it's calm and and then did
you get paid for it I told them the
charge was happy to be part of a live
stream I adore the full thing to be part
of it was enough for me it's a mental we
should have been presenting that [__]
but anyway the point is moving on thanks
to all the youtubers who supported me I
don't want it like Pete Gibbons by way
just let me say it give that name a full
shot on the podcast [__] you two have
worked you two have worked very closely
so get to this flat yes soapy became
like cause Pete's like he's about my
size would you say but he's like a real
chilled out dude and he actually like
helped me a lot in not acting like a
maniac
you know I mean like I've calmed down a
lot and learned from him over with
someone who was right Brian Brian and
him had like a lot of life
crossovers yeah and Pete looked down I
was like we should work together so I
want to show up Pete I want to start
with Stewart MacDonald who's also like a
bit of an uncle sort of me as weak so
Nick Selma so at the beginning of our
coral contract Nick looked after us with
just making sure that stuff was like
down the line and stressed over that for
days when there was no lawyers in the
room it was just Nick and Pete that was
big yeah I'm worried looking to forget
people get I just want to made and I
just want to make sure like so in terms
of youtubers
but I was [__] topless I feel like
probably joella's a fair show from the
outside this is supposed to be supposed
to be - I'm saying from the outside
world right that's how I see I want to
say it so specifically I remember when
ksi if JJ came on the [__] channel
that was a real big boost for me I saw
that the views you know Madness do you
remember this game he's never done a
podcast as well so and not an interview
where we really ask them like like what
porn do you watch is like you remember
that day when it was I know it'd be like
what was it facials like bro he watches
the crazy but he really hos it J Jay in
my opinion is the reason why we're all
four sitting around a fight in the
property I wouldn't have a career and
loads of we wouldn't have a [__] the
god big guy lives upon us all on his Mac
you carry those to the next small in
everyone's digits something it doesn't
matter you can look at anything forgot
someone
lucky to name it when I had 10,000
subscribers 78 tweet and he went up
knowing nothing about football but I
know you're amazing
he said that's alright boogie2988 oh
yeah I love boogie before squally and I
was just like what if he thinks I'm good
then I might be good actually tweed you
again recently there didn't know he was
shoving it Logan for me
his energy is quality though he's like
all he's energy like so thanks to him
[Music]
who else do it all thanks to mate
there's gonna be so many peopIe means
Spencer back Spencer I mean the
hodgetwins for being like really
inspirational to me back in the day I
look I used to look there for nail
Ranger to be [__] sheep but a lot of
people are saying I should get knowledge
on the hundredth podcast see you guys
are just 200 so yeah so like Pete and
Stu and all the good guys who've worked
with us especially behind the scenes of
the case I want I want to show the lads
behind the scenes to kick off because
they without them we would probably be
[__] so honestly the kickoff like I've
been a guest on it's so easy to do like
you know there's no good but the
production value in it is ridiculous and
the fact that you're just there is
having a good time with your mates and
at the same time and then I watch it
back to mind
Ian's analysis I just want to name them
especially you know thunks for bringing
his odd area because like I think my
second bug you
Elliot basically told coral that they
could trust us despite every bad thing
I've said in the past and like basically
helped change my life so I le 't like
life basically you see that and on top
of us he could literally easily be on
camera as the fifth member
yeah no I think that stuff is it he's
gonna be well he's definitely gonna be
scoring goals for X or se but we need
big a minimum but we need him on camera
still not if Roble have love for not
leaving
second-last kanji everyone always knows
Conan J from behind the cameras on the
podcast
they've been here every step of the way
Kahn's currently helping kiss I make
sounds like something like we when you
feel comfortable around the people
behind the camera you always make your
best videos like that makes a difference
so shows the other way is real when most
people feel comfortable enough around
you to like fall asleep
fart text cons falling asleep a few too
many videos oh my it's sort of annoying
that corn marsuit Khan who doesn't have
a hundred thousand subscribers had made
show before I did a million subscribers
[Music]
last but not least the man who changed
me like more than anyone else Lawrence
[Music]
can I just say I didn't see his also for
the Roxy it's like the weirdest match
made in heaven because you look at both
of you ago these two shouldn't be within
[__] 10 miles with each other right
but at the same time nothing makes a
podcast more than him thinking you're
disgusting and you and he has no idea
what he's going on about so that for me
is what just make sabzi permit and it's
so important
thanks to everyone and all the
subscribers for me in my life a lot
better now let's help your lives let's
answer some [__] easy
this one the eye infection is out filiz
first one is entitled queefing
I've had a girlfriend now for about two
months and a couple of weeks ago I
finally sealed my deal I think he means
that sex come on issues he had a
girlfriend and then he had sex right
yeah so I'm assuming 7:17 the issue is
that she queefs a lot too bad at first I
thought it wasn't too bad and I thought
it would be one a one-time thing she
doesn't do it the whole time
but she now do it does it every time I
like her but this is ridiculous
[Music]
should I talk to her about it we'll just
leave it because he is the issue
he's the issue PS congratulations on one
main queefing is caused by air being
trapped any penis leaving in space while
I'm trying to say is yeah you're being a
[__] for saying that like some girls
yeah no doubt some girls definitely do
it more than other ones but like the fat
do commit bro you need to stop what
brings born in that sense why it is so
normal for chicks to do that and if
you're [__] coming at your chicks a
and that's what a waffle then sort your
[__] out because you're one thing I will
say is the a lot of people say that
queefing is down to like people being
big that's not true me anyways the next
question bro okay here we go person
needs to sort their [__] yes this one's
just titled life problem why any noise
sure insects are any noise I'll take it
no fine I mean we're not having sex
right
as when a woman mourns anything I'm good
right okay okay you talked is that
enhancer experience right right okay do
you like it brown when they whisper it
to you I'm gonna shout it shout it right
really I'm a time I want a woman showing
at me unless were a woman but it's 100 I
don't want to show at all next question
here we go is just entitled life problem
I have this best mate and I'm deeply in
love with her
oh wow so we was at local spoons talking
I like this one cuz he talks about being
a witness with local spoons talking
about how neither of us have had sex in
a while and then she randomly offered if
I'd hat want to have sex with her my
issue here is that she's lesbian and I'm
scared that as soon as I'm as soon as
it's over we're just not going to talk
to each other help me this problem
because he says he's deeper with her but
she's a lesbian she's she not by right
so she's over time sex bisexual surely
she wants it but if you want at once do
you I have a best friend and I'm deeply
in love with her
how do you how do you reconcile I mean
firstly it sounds like an elbow she's
offering you sexually she is a little I
mean I don't have any places because no
so the girl he says is lesbian but she's
just him sex so we're saying the girl is
bicycle she's really not a lesbian he
was madly in love with her but she just
wants sex that has to be his finest
performance ever Primus is not a word
that has to be his finest performance
ever finest performance yes nobody edgy
like watch what needs
in here is they should have sex is what
it is because it's one of those things
that even if you're amazed with someone
if you have a sexual attraction to them
and they to you you're [__] right we
just saw yeah
socially awkward this one's titled don't
really have a big confusing problem but
I'm just a bit unconfident and I don't
know how to speak to girls or anyone for
that matter so if you want to give me a
master class on how to talk to women
go ahead I feel like we defer to
daughter here who's got the most
subscribers and also the most no one's
had you talk to Sophie so he says women
second he says people he essentially he
needs to be in my opinion more confident
in himself more than anything where does
that come from you so there's a very
wise man called Nikki Aras once told me
you have to be your own best friend Wow
so especially when 25 years in prison
23 years and you have to you have to
just reassure yourself of
I am good enough you know this person
isn't above me and I think when you're
young when you're a young man you look
at a good-looking girl and you put the
[__] on a pedestal Wow
you imagine I am this I am not with you
are worthy of her [__] you're worthy
you know I'm saying
gone but worthy we're all the boys we're
all worthy lads that's all I'm trying to
say and we're worthy and just don't
overestimate she probably likes you as
much as you like her if you're looking
to girls so do you ever have moments
Brian cause I had moments where I don't
feel social and sometimes I'm in a
social situation I'm not feeling 100%
social and maybe some people I'm just
saying like do you ever have night cuz
that sometimes your parties and you have
to almost like flick a switch and go
right it's just hyung-tae social for
laughs you know I mean yourself mentally
just I am interesting I've read an
interesting thing today I've done an
interesting - pretty it's not hairy
enough it's too pretty
I don't have another mouse is too pretty
bumpiness from from my visit this guy
doesn't have enough self-confidence I'm
gonna assume that he is relatively young
it I would say what does he give an age
no so I would say sinkings everything
honestly mate the best thing you can do
is just focus on yourself for now and on
Cory about chase focus on your summer
now if you're not feeling confident go
to the gym go play ASP or cop
just try and make yourself as
extroverted as possible and there's no
problem if you tried that and you said
you know what it's not for me I'm an
introverted person I totally find a lot
people are introverted just for me
personally when I used to talk to girls
one of the things that used to [__] it
up for me the most was I would think
total girl I'm talking with girls so if
you just think forget that she's a girl
he's going to help you instantly you
have some men make some headway is there
also a point though where you flip from
I'm talking to a girl too that you're
sharp when you talk to I'll be honest
though it's lacquered you good in my
opinion for now you really need to
improve your own personal confidence I'm
so sorry this is gone too [__] [__]
I'll do my best to hold it together
ego Cal okay so a lot of people write in
with messages that are usually jokes but
I have an actual serious message one of
my friends got like one of my friends
and I fell out essentially without going
into too much detail she told a horrible
lie like like none like none of that oh
I didn't eat the cookie blah blah blah
but basically she told a horrible lie he
doesn't say the lie but he makes joke
about it well we fell out a few months
ago and recently she's been messaging me
again saying that she wanted to you know
[__] no just be friends what do you do
when a friend lies to you a very serious
lie is a girl or a girl so this is a guy
oh no sorry it's actually a girl go with
go a girl longer yeah yeah
one it was a joke it was a joke it was a
bad joke it's a bad joke basically out
yeah yeah I mean look Brian if I lied to
you how's that look mate I can't I can't
I yeah well no that's that's me can I
start see one question were talking
about a lie-detector video have you ever
have you ever fainted a punch right have
you ever have you ever have you ever
have you ever pulled a punch on the
lie-detector test where you thought I
could ask this question no never never
ask anyone and that's a problem that's
why so many people have declined
including yourself I didn't and that
could mean questions real love bro but
in terms of this person here do you know
it so it like Brian if I lied to you and
I said look man I can't come on your 1
million podcast because I've got my
girlfriend's parents that I meet maybe
like Stephen you pretended like you were
ill or something yeah yeah no I just
told my parents I'm me or dad
Gumble rally tickets what would you say
if I like because you know I'd be
terribly disappointed but I wouldn't let
you confront me about it okay I'd let
you I'm fine okay but seriously I told
between and this I think the difference
two female friends so it's not a golf
girl to a boy it's two girls I think not
under boy and finding part of this it
really makes a [__] difference
I think it does I think there are
differences in relations chips between
male and female female female male male
but I build relationships in different
ways so men
Podcast you're more than welcome to jet
right now because this is about to be a
[__] show it's gonna be a [__] show of
an ending but me and Lawrence are gonna
carry this [__] to the end Lawrence is
gonna be care so not Lauren's
[__] Bryan is gonna come along
with us but we've lost well guys will
speak about you two girlfriends how many
girls are starting instagram's off for
the [__] of their boyfriends on us are
we saying
instagrams do you think it's a bad thing
if someone gets in a relationship and
then during their girlfriends they don't
need a relationship I mean you can also
be called that it Crawford install
YouTube channel view me I'm literally
talking about like you can though I also
see your point like so he was friends
with Joe and he saw that Joe's do money
thought I'll start my own YouTube
channel is that such a bad thing make
the peace whilst you can securely bug is
fine that Donnie made his pee fine
that's totally fine he's at who's next
time I'm a [__] chopping board you
know because I'm a lot of I don't see
anyone I mean who's I I'm one of the few
single [__] out there right in
sisters there's nothing you know my
[__] choice yeah but I am really
[__] trying to find someone that has
good it has a good crack that enjoys a
lot you need the bun a minute that's
what I need someone that is gonna have a
good laugh you also need someone who
you're gonna respect though I feel like
you need you rate like how many people
would be dated where you thought
good numbers I'll go into names
[Music]
experiences where you've thought a
little bit no no it's a judgment at the
person but just like you know what
you're not for me
Chile there's a lot of people like I
feel like different I can't stand being
bored you often tell me about how bored
you were when you were in multiple
relationships right but most of all in
terms of monogamy Brian what's your way
out of ten what's up naca me you know
that's called G right why did you have
[Applause]
it's a big difference
can I just ask you what's the judgement
from North people about South people but
can we not go into too much I want to
say on this so basically so basically
one must call oh god I can't really see
anything
the point is Jonah a and B they they
have very similar names and I'd often
almost call them each other's name but
you go is that I mean like similar
almost to like one letter like Amanda
and a member and I just say my rule is
you should only [__] one woman at one
period in your life like you shouldn't
be [__] multiple women from your own
rule in it and if any men are listening
you know exactly why I'm saying that
because Brian is also slept the sir
brian has been when he sing one more
normal man at any point in his life okay
I told you not to mention that name you
know I you know I actually love is that
in the beginning of the podcast I never
could have made that joke but now he
dismisses it in the begin of the podcast
if I don't made a joke that Brian was
gay it would have been like when you
keep telling me I'm [__] gay maybe
[Music]
Lauren's wrong called true you know what
Brian
one day so do you think it's a bad thing
if someone gets into a relationship and
then they realize I can profit also from
this relationship after having
conversations with a person who's
successful time out of social media I
mean let's say I'm way to 1.30 so listen
yeah I'm there I got the breasts out I'm
ready
they're back I just been hitting to to
squat to the gym I'm riding I'm just
there doing my thing you're a fine piece
you come into my dear straight in
Laurens McKenna my drums when I'm CK Wow
very well write our wife you know right
the first thing that's Ruben is also is
it's a heart back to all the podcasts we
got called a call right so say that this
has happened a million times on YouTube
already like only our sue a lot of
people do you think it's a bad thing
that you're trying to build subscribers
off someone who's with one some of those
got over a million something as awful
three why I think it's wrong but why so
say you've been out on a couple of dates
with that guy and that guy listened to
you and no but that guy's saying to you
like sir I make money from this I make
money from posting and you know what I
see a lot of girls that do that as well
you should do it you're beautiful I mean
there's a reason why I keep all of my
religion of anyone that I ever see is
will never feature on any of my social
medias
right
what what if she was real absolute
[__] ten cuz we all know she's no
ronaldo cristiano ronaldo the man who's
got the pick of all the [__] women
let's be honest and the man he kit
bought whatever he wants
yeah anyways anyways no he'd never pulls
out and then one day she's arena shake
would pull up
would you ever see was the one have you
met the one one would you be like
because why change up what you be
because the rule changes when you feel
is a long-term partner therefore it's
never about you she could she like us
not what you can do for your but you
know well your youtube i can do for you
ask what you can do for your youtuber
this guy was amen brother the guy you've
just quoted has been shot in the head by
his own government all right I guess
what what did his wife do she run for
ourselves
she didn't look after him her big fat
ass was claiming over the [__] GF
kids go run and check here we go though
shadow a Jeff kids wife she had a
[__] badonkadonk he was bleeding to
death
her fat ass was claiming that car
looking her lump let's just say no long
no one ever looked at JFK's wife in that
situation and when she a thick girl can
we agree can also say they have kids
wife sobriety have you ever heard the
story about the the third brother so
could be
[Music]
I feel like what you want in what Cali
sayin is you want someone who is almost
it's a bit like Ocean's eleven right so
there's that opening scene in Ocean's
eleven where all the famous people I
have no idea where you're cool with this
well you'll see I feel like there's that
opening scene erosions 11 where all the
famous people are playing cards right
Brad Pitt's in that room but he's not
Brad Pitt he's a nobody he walks out the
club and Brad Pitt adjusts his tie still
a very attractive man he's still someone
who's got a lot of money in life he's
making a good living but he walks
straight past the crowd and he doesn't
have the problem with the crowd the
famous people have to stop for the crowd
you don't want to burden your girlfriend
with that same thing you want her to be
able to walk out in public and be able
to walk around a free person without the
burden of your fame because actually
you're we're treating it on this side of
the table as famous the benefit actually
we're treating on this side of the table
is that's not the real bet yeah benefits
I feel like Kyle's not it right so my
big thing is I genuinely think Fame is
not what people are actually chasing for
I don't think Fame is what what people
I'm sorry to get really deep on this no
no I like where you're gone this good
good so I think same I think Fame is
truly something that people they idolize
it's something that they want and in
their head being told that is incredible
to be known but you know I think because
I think it's about that upbringings is
like for whatever reason they haven't
felt like a whole person right like
their thing and they searched him for
some validation of well when I'm famous
and everyone loves me then I'll feel
perfect for me it's it's [__] like
it's a when people come up recognize in
the street and have thought was with you
it's a lovely little moment and it's a
nice to be appreciated but ten seconds
later you're back to being just you
you're not I mean like and only if you
really rate yourself do you take that on
board any more than that like only if
you're ego-driven do you actually think
oh yeah I see where you're coming from
but I also feel like it speaks to
something which is in everyone that like
it speaks that animal side of you that
you want to spread your tribe like you
want your people to be dominant you want
like what you believe in your mind
whether whether it's a right or a wrong
thought like you want what you believe
and what you hold there to be spread
amongst people so when someone else
comes to you and says like a watch your
channel i mimic your beliefs and I
believe like you're someone who can lead
people that there's something some form
of endorsement there like that has
always been going around the world like
people wanted to dominate other cultures
because they wanted their cottage I
don't know if I would maybe I've reduced
it someone said something to me is one
of the laws l'm shut out your crew you
know what that chat is actually quite
idea gets varied enough for real but
then one of them said I've never
connected with a youtuber more maybe
smarter that I thought that was really
so I felt like that actually like I read
that I was like I don't know like we all
get tweets like that nice sweet spot
like that was such a chopping up a
little bit like I'm like you really
identify what about that me it meant so
every now and then it's good to be moved
but it's not gonna get swept away and
that's the difference is that actually
so we're just [__] people
so kangaskhan took it too far but there
are other people who are like who want
their ideology to spread and i do feel
like there's something that i'm and it
doesn't justify it cuz a lot of menus
that like i just want to [__] every
woman because it's if i'm an animal like
that's not the way that sorry he's
regurgitating my belief
it doesn't just allow that no no laws is
a bit Konya though on you like let's be
honest here you really are a little bit
you're a little bit con you what you've
got a creative stricking you like and
you'd like to have things that you've
created take over oh absolutely
you know make some in 510 feels mine but
i
I guess you if you have that awareness
of that then are you ever gonna be like
what kind of so ever it's never fully
yours is it it's never fully it's always
influenced but you know what yeah and
and you can't help that and you never
could help but you guys got the
experience I mean I have my experience
made famous but you had the experience
but I have experienced being like a
low-level I don't have that I don't have
anyone who I appreciate there you've
literally got a cult who follow you
called the loss limbs no no but like if
it be strong its future like 50 likely
they put their group chatters like
nothing I've ever seen like they're
literally anything but their own podcast
called and Ozlem it's a great podcast
come Kirkham has been against wills guy
this was our first podcast in the new
studio very grateful everyone who's
helped me get here I kind of I'm pretty
sure forgotten a few people but I'm
sorry if I how should we just say one
thing this was something that in January
Brian the producer kick off and I sat
down and went when are we gonna hit a
million like when are you gonna hit
million weapon you know what I mean like
we spoke as a group because we everyone
the best in your project and we said
when are we gonna hit a million let's
celebrate that and Brian turn to us and
well I don't know if it will be this
year but it will be sometime soon and I
know maybe we were being humble and
maybe a bit disparaging for a reason
shut up Logan yeah but no one thought
that it would be not point to where it
was overnight where we went we'd that
we'd have any time to prepare but for
plant pots or an upside down with it you
know although I'm equally shitty I think
that represents my time on YouTube just
both just perfectly like you've turned
but it's kinda cool no one thought that
it would be like that and that and that
was it and tell you why though because I
spent so many hours and lives people
talk about the ten thousand hours
talking to a [__] camera practicing
so that when anyone tried to call me out
on something I really try to come after
me I was like a [__] summer I just
sitting there just dormant like you
don't know who I am but
willwill on the other hand he's been
picking fights for years so he's trained
it's one of those things aside you know
people just look at YouTube ah all these
eyes there was a few months in front of
them and they hooked up to a computer
and they they have their podcast people
actually realize the time the effort not
from just others like we've got one to
another and there's gonna be three four
or five people that look after this
video before it goes out because it's
like people just don't appreciate the
effort that goes into and because it
looks so effortless effortless here it's
such a testament to the people behind
the camera the effort they put in and
all this just shocked oh one more I
wanna shout Jill who edits a lot of it
you know yeah we forgot about Geoghan
he's a fairly recent addition and he's
our newest sort of team member so but I
would have to say one of the most
valuable people you know real he's an
editor who graphs hard got a great
creative streak in him and his attitude
is superb like if you have a team member
you want someone who like gives it all
in in darker moments Gio makes everyone
worry about the next generation of the
creators because he is he's it's so
slick the way the oh yeah I know a dark
no no like in a way where you look at me
think [__] I don't know if I could
replicate that but he's so good wait
those brews and for that reason why I
think he's not gonna make I thought I
keep worrying that haven't everyone so
all the subscribers like especially the
long-term guys no offense to the newbie
but like you thought you were I'm quite
prepared to go back to the views that I
was getting beforehand and I'd be quite
happy to do that and quite happy just
sit and talking about the same old [__]
I've always done thanks this even tries
we haven't mentioned Steven but Steven
no no we mention him enough he just
unfortunately ill today he would have
been here had he had not been ill yeah
then he would had me being a tag-along
let me just say this Stevens ill for
eight to ten years we don't know
and anyway thanks to the subscribers
I love years old thanks to everyone
who's helped us are really appreciative
and we will see you on the next one
cheers everyone